ازمه تصريح الموظفين في قطاع التكنولوجيا
ما زالت مستمره ويبقى السؤال ما الذي حل
بهذا القطاع حتى وصل الى هذا الحد من
تراجع الارباح واللجوء الى تخفيض عدد
الموظفين وتسريحهم يقول خبراء التكنولوجيا
ان قطاع التكنولوجيا شهد طفره ارباح
خلالها انتشار فايروس كورونا لان بعد
الاغلاق في دول العالم لجا الموظفون الى
العمل عن بعد وكانت العائلات تؤمن
مشترياتها من خلال متاجر الانترنت هذا فضل
طبعا عن النمو في شركات الالعاب والافلام
على الانترنت اما امام هذا الواقع طبعا
مشاهدينا لاجيء لجات شركات تكنولوجيا عده
الى التوسع وساده عدد الموظفين كي تلاقي
ارتفاع الطلب وزياده الارباح ولكن بعد
انحار كورونا حصلت صدمه في هذا القطاع ولم
يعد الطلب على التكنولوجيا كما كان في
العام 2020 ما غير المعدلات
بتاعتي عوامل اخرى طبعا تضاف ادت الى ضرب
قطاع التكنولوجيا مثل ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده والتضخم والمخاوف من الركود
العالم الاقتصادي كل هذه الامور ساهمت
بتراجع الاعلانات طبعا وانفاق المستهلكين
ماثر على ارباح شركات التكنولوجيا واسعار
الاسهم خلال الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه اعلنت
كبريات شركات التكنولوجيا مثل امازون
وجوجل ومايكروسوفت عن خطط لتسريح اكثر من
50,000 موظف وهو واقع معكس للاشهر الاولى
من الوباء